on june the 1st 1310
a woman was brought to the public square
in paris
she had been accused and convicted of
heresy by the church because of a
controversial book that she had written
and on that day she was burned at the
stake
a horrific way to die only reserved for
what the church considered to be the
worst of sinners
and a sad end for one of the most
interesting women of the middle ages
the book she had written and for which
she was executed is known as
the mirror of simple souls it would be
published and spread anonymously after
the author's death and ironically became
quite popular in somewhat of a classic
in circles of christian mysticism
it is only in the 1940s that the author
of this amazing work
was identified as the person who we will
talk about today
the french mystic marguerite porrett
[Applause]
this video is brought to you by our
patreon community who
supports this channel monetarily and
provides much needed caffeine in the
form of tea for when i need to work
so thank you so much to all of my
patrons if you want to become a patron i
will leave a link to all that stuff in
the
description marguerite porret
was born into a tumultuous time in 13th
century europe
and in france to be precise a time of
great scholarly activity with the
flourishing of the great universities
and with
scholastic figures like thomas aquinas
meister eckhart
albert the greats among many others the
context in which she lived is important
in order to understand not only her
writings and ideas
but also why she was deemed a heretic
and treated so harshly
while other similar figures of other
periods were not
this was a period when the church ruled
supreme of course
and over the course of the 13th century
and definitely by the early 14th
the church had become a lot more
restrictive and
quick to for example deem people as
heretics and there are probably several
reasons for this there were
a lot of inner turmoil and conflict
within the church and it was a
rather uncertain time in europe
generally and especially in the church
and this probably led to this more
restrictive
approach and attitude at the time but
one
very important factor in the 13th
century was the so-called begin
movement this was a movement of women
who live
semi-monastic lives in other words
these were people who often lived in
monastic communities
lead chased lives didn't marry and in
any ways
lived similar lives to how monks and
nuns lived
with the exception that they didn't take
any formal
monastic vows the begins didn't marry as
long as they were begins
but they could also choose to leave and
live normal lives at any time they chose
this movement was very influential in
the 13th century and provided some of
the most significant christian mystics
in history
it is with the begins that we get people
like hadevich and
mehchtil of magdeborg who in their
writings like
especially in mexico's classic the
flowing light of the godhead
not only pioneered the use of vernacular
language for religious expression by
writing in german but also a new way of
talking about the mystical relationship
and union with god that they had
experienced
while the begin movement was rather
admired by a lot of people in the
beginning
over the course of the 13th century so
by the late
13th century and and especially the
early 14th century
they began to be looked upon with a lot
of suspicion the
ambiguous social and religious role of
these
begin women bothered the pope and the
other
church authorities they of course didn't
belong
formally within the church hierarchy
like nuns and monks did they were
part of the church system the beginnings
weren't in the same way
and yet at the same time they could hold
and and and have
significant religious influence and and
power in the regions where they were
located
and this begin movement will become very
important for the story of marguerite
poureth
as we will see but another very
important
development in the 13th century
christendom in europe
was another movement that was referred
to as the
heresy of the free spirit this
wasn't a specific movement or group of
people
but more a kind of general tendency
among certain christians at the time
which was greatly opposed and criticized
by the church
and the word heresy is a polemical word
that we shouldn't take
too seriously here of course but the
church was very serious about the
supposed group
what they are supposed to have believed
is hard to say with certainty because it
is fraught with so much polemical and
unbiased sources nonetheless in the
words of scholar frank tobin
quote those of the free spirit were
accused of maintaining that one can
attain a state in this life in which it
was impossible
to sin that in this state ascetical
practices are unnecessary
because reason is no longer affected by
the sensuality of the body
and hence one is free to accord to the
body all
one wishes and that in this state one is
not subject to the laws of the church
but has
freedom in the spirit of the lord they
were said to characterize the state of
perfection as the soul's annihilation in
the nothingness that is god on the other
hand
they were accused of teaching that god
can be an obstacle
to the attainment of perfection these
accusations
as formulated by the church are of
course hard to take
all that seriously because their pains
are very clearly
a caricature every unflattering
caricature of what these
supposed people of the free spirit are
supposed to have believed
but if we look at it in a more sort of
broad the broad outlines of what is said
here
it does remind us of some of the things
that marguerite poureth
does say in her book the mirror of
simple souls
and indeed when we talk about the heresy
of the free spirit
some of the people associated with that
movement is indeed
marguerite and also for example meister
eckhart
the doctrines of the free spirit were
formally condemned at the council of
vienna
in 1311-1312 and we can see
then that the time and place in question
was one of a lot of unrest and
uneasiness within the church having to
face a lot of inner
turmoil and trouble and controversial
developments and movements and it is
into this
environment that marguerite porret was
born probably in 1250
sadly as has become customary in these
episodes we don't know much at all about
marguerite's life
she was from france and was most likely
from a wealthy aristocratic family
due to the simple fact that she was
literate and was able to publish and
promote her works later in life
she is often associated with the begin
movement
already mentioned and is often thought
to have been or lived
as a begin for most of her life although
many scholars today doubt this as the
evidence is quite
slim in any case she certainly seems to
have lived a
religious life and if her writings are
anything to go by
she seems to have had some very intense
mystical experiences of being
annihilated in and united with god
it is these experiences that she would
try to explicate later on
in her writings it seems that she wrote
the first
version of her masterpiece the mirror of
simple souls
sometime in the 1290s now instead of
writing this book in
latin the accepted and most popular
language for religious texts
she followed the earlier begins and
mystics by writing a book in a
vernacular language
in this case french something that was
quite controversial in itself at the
time
because indeed she would soon run into
some trouble
she started circulating this book
showing it to different people but
a few years later some church
authorities were outraged by the book
deemed it heretical and chose to have it
burned
but marguerite persisted she continued
to write and continue to spread her book
which of course further provoked her
critics in
1308 she was arrested and handed to the
inquisitor of france william of
paris and placed in prison alongside one
of her supporters
a beggard by the name of guillard de
cresson nessart
one of the things that the inquisitors
wanted to achieve by putting her in
prison
was probably to make her recant her
ideas or to take her
book or the statements in her book back
but she instead
continuously refused over and over again
she would not recant her ideas
and stood by the statement she had made
in her book
she also refused to take part in the
trial against her
which resulted in her prison stay being
extended to over
two years now her prison mate her
supporter guillard
was eventually well he eventually
confessed
so to say and was put in prison uh
or remained in prison i should say
whereas marguerite would just
continuously
refuse to give in to the inquisitors
finally then
in 1310 the inquisitors decided to go
ahead with the trial without her
participation
they examined certain sections from her
book and decided that they were
indeed heretical and after allowing
marguerite the opportunity to recant her
views to save her life
only to be met again by her strong
refusal they handed her over to these
secular authorities for execution
then the rest of the unfortunate story
you already know
this probably raises a lot of questions
for some of you mainly
what is it about this book that was so
controversial or
what does this book actually say for
many of us the fact that this book was
so met with so much opposition and even
led to her execution
just makes us want to read it even more
and when we do read it we find a
fascinating and sophisticated mystical
and philosophical work
that explores the soul's relationship to
god
and their union with each other the book
takes the form of a dialogue between
different characters
each of which represents abstract
concepts
the three main characters are the soul
probably referring to margarite herself
then there is the character
love who advises the soul about god and
the experience of mystical union
and lastly there is reason who acts as
he can kind of counteract
always questioning her statements and
acting as the
well as the voice of reason this dynamic
is at the core of the book love is
clearly the source of ultimate wisdom to
marguerite and represents her own views
and teachings
it is daring shocking and mystical it
isn't
philosophical rational arguments but
ineffable
mystical knowledge that is conveyed by
the character love
but margherita was fully aware of how
some of the statements that love makes
in the book
sounds and that it can easily be
understood as
controversial you could say and this is
why the character of
reason is so important so reason always
comes in and
questions the statements made by love
love will say something outrageous
uh like when the soul is united to god
the soul lets go of all virtues and then
the reason we'll jump in and say
how on earth could you say something
like that what do you mean please
explain
and then love will explain even more and
so on so
this dynamic is cons constantly
at the core of the narrative and the way
that this book is structured the
character reason obviously represents
not only
well reason itself and its limitations
in understanding the realities of
mystical love
but also the critics and scholastics of
the church at the time
in a very clever way she's kind of
responding to the criticisms that would
be thrown at her
even before they were so to say here's
an example quote
love says this soul cares not of shame
nor of worship nor of poverty nor of
riches nor of ease or disease
nor of love or hate nor of hell or
paradise
then reason responds oh love by god what
is this that you are saying
love responds what is this to say only
those whom god has given understanding
can know
for no scripture teaches it nor can
reason comprehend it
or the travailing of deserts reach it
but it is a gift given by the most high
in whom this creature is lost in knowing
and becomes annihilated
in her understanding through this
fascinating dialogue
marguerite tells us that the soul can
become completely annihilated in god
that it can become one and united to god
fully
so that nothing of the individual
remains
and one of the most important themes in
this wider topic
one of the central themes in this book
is the question of
will for puert the goal of the mystical
quest as well as the result
of union with god is for the individual
will of the person
to be completely eradicated now all of
us have
wills and desires upon which we act in
basically every moment of our lives
now i am hungry which means i will to
eat and thus i will make some dinner
now i will to worship god so i go to
church
and so on but for marguerite poret all
of this is a hindrance to reaching god
instead we should stop willing all
together so that there is no trace of
will
left in the soul we shouldn't even will
to know or worship god himself
and when the soul becomes united with
god and thus the will of the person is
non-existent
god's will becomes her will
quote reason says are you saying that
the soul has no will at
all love responds truly no
for everything that she wills by her
consent is that which god wills that she
would will
and this she wills so that the will of
god may be accomplished
not at all her own will and she cannot
will this of herself
but it is the will of god that wills it
in her and so it is clear
that this soul has no will at all that
she has to will
in other words there is only god's will
now being
enacted through the person the idea here
is that
the will of the individual person is
just completely non-existent
it's annihilated as eradicated
radically and only god's will is what
remains there is only god's will and
anything that the person will do from
then on
will be through the will of god and not
through the will of their own soul
this argument again is the main thrust
of the entire book
and the consequences of this idea of the
world being eradicated
is the reason why this book upsets so
many people
indeed what margaret porrett argues is
that when
the will of the individual soul is
annihilated
completely the person has to become
united to god
and their will is gone this means that
the person
does not have to abide by the virtues
or by virtues at all that means that
once the person is united to god and his
will is
gone this means he doesn't have to go to
church
this means that he doesn't have to give
to the poor
or follow the laws of the church
undoubtedly very shocking stuff to a
medieval european
audience quote love says the soul of
such love may say to the virtues
i take leave of you to which virtues
this soul has been a servant for so long
the soul says i ascend lady love so i
was then but now your courtesy has
delivered me in this way
out of this bondage therefore i say
virtues
i take leave of you forever now my heart
shall be more free and at peace than it
ever was
oh i was then your servant but now i am
delivered out of your thraldom
however as always things aren't so
simple
we see here clear parallels to the
doctrines ascribed to the controversial
heresy of the free spirit that we talked
about earlier
which immediately caused trouble for
marguerite now if you remember my
episode about the contemporary christian
mystic meister eckhart
you remember that he presented very
similar arguments
indeed many argue that eckhart probably
had read the mirror of simple souls and
was inspired by it
but in both cases when they talk about
this state of will's non-existence
and its ethical consequences what
eckhart calls living without a y
they don't really mean what it seems
like they mean
understandably the inquisitors and
critical scholars took this doctrine to
mean
that the person united with god was
relieved of religious and social
obligation
that they could live their lives without
following the laws of the church
but this is not what porret is saying or
eckhart for that matter
instead what she means is that when the
person is fully united to god and her
will has become eradicated so only
god's will remains she quote-unquote
doesn't have to be
virtuous because she no longer has any
will to do so
she doesn't have to will going to church
or follow the laws
but she still does it through the will
of god in
theological language talking about god
doesn't have to choose to do the right
thing he just
does the right thing because he is god
and so the united soul will still be
virtuous
the person will still worship god and
respect the church
but it will not do so by its own will
but rather
you could say kind of automatically by
the will of god
who is now willing through this soul
this seemingly flew over the heads of
the inquisitors
who only saw in this text a crude kind
of anti-nominalism
and thus they deemed it heretical and so
it was that margarite was
condemned for these statements made in
her book
and as we saw earlier she still refused
to recanter ideas or to fall
to the pressure of the inquisitors even
at the threat of death
on the day of her execution bystanders
are said to have been brought to tears
by the calmness with which podet faced
her end
perhaps as a result of her firm
conviction that the ideas she had
presented
were indeed true and so ends the story
of one of the most fascinating figures
of medieval christianity
a woman who dared to present bold ideas
and stood her ground even
to her last breath the mirror of simple
souls has become a classic
of mystical literature and was
circulated in history under anonymous
authorship
until it could be determined in the mid
20th century
that the author was indeed margarite
porret the text is
incredibly difficult to get through
even in a lucid modern english
translation
but if you have the time and energy to
attempt it i highly recommend you check
out this book it's a
fascinating read and it's a look into a
form of christianity that many people
aren't perhaps familiar with today
and also into a time and place in
medieval europe
that is that is very interesting very
fascinating very important
for for a lot of different reasons it
shows us not only how a religion like
christianity is
internally diverse but also that even in
the most restrictive of environments
there will always be people who dare to
present ideas that are innovative
and unique i'll see you next time
[Music]
you